inflation in the united states just came
in at a brand new 40-year high the
official number for the month of june is
9.1
according to the cpi this is absolutely
insane in one of the most developed and
one of the largest economies in the
world now if we take a look as to what
is driving this 9.1 percent inflation
number you can see that there's a whole
bunch of chaos underneath it
first fuel oil is up almost 100
over the last 12 months
gasoline is up 60 percent electricity is
up 13.7 percent new cars are up 11.4
transportation of 8.8 used cars up 7
and shelter allegedly is only up 5.6
but the number that jumps out to me here
is none of those it's instead the cost
of eating food at home has increased
more than 12
over the last year that is completely
unsustainable for the average american
family now one of the things that the
inflation numbers tend to hide is that
real wage growth is not growing it's
going down meaning that most people in
the american economy are actually
getting paid less money today than they
were a year or two years ago here's a
great way to look at it we've got this
chart that shows all of the u.s wage
growth since the start of the borrowing
and printing binge has been a mirage up
12.3 percent in nominal terms but it's
actually negative negative 1.5 percent
after adjusting for higher prices as
charlie points out initially everyone
loves free money it's only with the
passage of time that the ravages of
inflation are revealed another way to
think about this is that you may be
getting paid more dollars but those
dollars are worth less in purchasing
power terms it means that you're not
getting a raise fast enough to keep up
with the rising prices so you're
actually in a worse position now the
loose monetary policy and the
undisciplined fiscal policy that the
united states has pursued for the last
two years we mitigated the short-term
pain caused by kovid and the government
lockdowns and all that liquidity crisis
in march and april of 2020 but it was at
the cost of the long-term pain of high
inflation and we now sit with a 40-year
high but there's a word of caution
there's a lot of people who will start
to say that inflation is coming down but
they don't actually understand math
if you look at this chart from heather
long what you can see is that plenty of
people will point to this pink line
which shows core inflation that does not
include food and energy and they'll say
look it's starting to come down but the
problem is as heather points out gas
energy groceries and rent are all rising
sharply and so you can manipulate data
to have that pink line come down but the
blue line that includes everything
including energy and food which is a
staple purchase for every american
family we continue to see inflation
rising now of course when you have math
anyone can manipulate the numbers to say
whatever they want but if you go to the
grocery store you go out to eat if you
try to purchase goods and services in
the economy what you can tell is that
prices are much higher than they've
previously been
and wages are not keeping up pushing
people into further and further dire
situations at the end of the day 9.1
percent inflation in the official
reading is likely inaccurate but if we
go ahead and give them the benefit of
the doubt and we say that inflation
actually is 9.1 percent that's almost
double digits and in a developed country
like the united states of america
which serves as one of the largest
economies in the world
that is absolutely disastrous and so
either they're gonna have to get this
under control or people will continue to
suffer and unfortunately most americans
have no clue what to do with inflation
this high